(audience cheering)
- Wow.
- [Kelly] So have y'all met before?
Y'all worked together right?
- We worked together.
- Yes, we did.
- Yep.
- With my very good friend
and late John Ritter.
Bless his soul.
- Yes.
- Was the first time we met.
- And we met backstage.
- Yes.
- I was gonna say to Zosia (laughing)
we go way back? (laughing)
- We go way way back
to like 25 minutes ago.
- Yes.
And what a full 25 minutes it's been.
- Honestly feels like a lifetime.
- Did the chemistry
ignite with y'all as well
(laughing) your friendship?
- I have to tell you
your conversation just now
was amazing because it was so relatable.
Now whether man or woman,
it was so open
and it was like you were two
just sitting in your living room.
- Oh, that's what I want
the show to feel like.
- Well, that's what it felt like.
- Oh that's so sweet.
(audience cheering)
- Okay. I've done my job.
- No (laughing).
I wanna talk...
How is your family?
How are your grandkids?
- Okay.
- I love how excited
grandparents get about grandkids.
(laughing)
- Okay. So we have six.
- Oh my God.
- And the newest is five months old.
- Oh.
Frances Joan.
And her mother and father
are bringing her tonight.
- [Kelly] Oh.
- Yes. In order to have a vacation.
At our house.
- [Kelly] So you're gonna help take care
while they get a little...
- Oh my God.
(laughing)
The last time that she was at our house
I fed her mushed banana
in a spoon with a spoon.
- [Kelly] It's magical.
- It is in my heart,
I'm telling you.
It makes me cry when I think about it.
- Yeah.
- Wait, I wanna talk about you more.
So you're TikTok now.
- Well, because of my granddaughter,
my older granddaughter.
- I know.
So did she force you to do that.
- 12 and nine.
- [Kelly] Okay.
- India and Lulu.
(audience laughing)
- [Kelly] Look at you.
- [Henry] Oh there they are!
- [Kaley] Oh my God, you must
be the best grandpa ever.
- You are the best grandpa ever!
- I mean I can't.
- And I gotta say,
at the very end it kinda looked
like you were twerking, sir.
(laughing)
- You know what,
if I get the chance I will twerk.
(laughing)
(audience cheering)
- If the spirit moves within me,
why fight it.
- The girls said, "Papa,
you have to be on TikTok."
And then they pick the music.
- [Kelly] Okay.
- And then they, one of
them, they're both dancers.
I mean truly gifted dancers
and they kind of pick what we're gonna do.
And then boom, we do it.
So the little one in the front is Lulu,
then is Ace.
Ace just turned 10.
We took him to Hamilton two weeks ago.
And then behind is India.
India is the choreographer.
- The choreographer, yeah.
Well you killed it.
- Thank you.
- You did.
I am not...
I've never done a dance.
I don't feel like going to,
have y'all done that yet?
- I refuse to join.
I can't.
(laughing)
This is where I say no.
- This is my line.
- Remember this conversation.
- I never thought I would,
but when you're shamed into it.
- Yeah. You have to do it.
- [Kelly] Shame is a powerful tool.
- Yes.
- And lemme just say 13 million views.
- It's insane.
- Well hello.
(audience cheering)